jobs jobs jobs and jobs
politicians are eager to do something
about jobs well here in California they
found one way to save and create certain
kinds of jobs public sector unions fight
layoffs by getting politically active if
someone wants to cut back spending you
know what the unions will say but
California has been spending and taxing
at record rates and the economy is still
lousy so what now tax the rich I think
we have no choice but to raise taxes the
whole state of California would in not
mind a half a cent more at this forum in
Los Angeles union members and political
candidates fought against job cuts and
called on businesses to pay higher taxes
this job creation strategy has worked
well California has added more than
160,000 unionized jobs even as the
private sector lost jobs
while the booze after all schwarzenegger
likes tax hikes too in 2009 he signed
the largest in state history and this
year Sacramento politicians are
pondering more hikes even though the
state already has one of the nation's
worst tax climates we paid their
salaries they wouldn't have jobs if we
didn't create our own jobs rick nukem
started Creators Syndicate in Los
Angeles in 1987 with the idea that
cartoonists should be able to own their
work we used to get ads or Oh Batman
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and from
Hillary Clinton to Bill O'Reilly
the company has syndicated many
well-known colonists today Newcombe runs
creators with a son Jack the company has
hundreds of clients dozens of employees
and one big decision to make
well our office lease is up in May 2011
and we have to decide they might move to
a different city or even a different
state we didn't want to leave but if
they don't reverse this of course we'll
leave there's no why would we stay a
form of madness tax madness has taken
over Sacramento California has one of
the nation's highest unemployment rates
but business is pretty good for Joe
Vrana ch you see he helps companies move
out of California I would love to have
companies calling me saying you know
what we'd like to move to California can
you help us with that relocation I get
none of those calls because I do get our
hello we want to move out of California
can you help us do that whether it was
the lure of gold Hollywood fame or high
tech fortune California has long been a
destination for those seeking a better
life the Golden State beauty remains but
the state's native-born population has
been leaving over the past decade so
many of us have left that it's
equivalent to the entire population of
the city of San Diego I probably heard
from more than a hundred entrepreneurs
and business owners who said to me we
are so glad we got out or we can't wait
to get out many others have gotten out
or expanded out of state but why would
anyone leave all this there is no one
reason that drives companies out of
California
if you want to bring businesses to
California let's eliminate this death by
a thousand cuts traffic congestion
that's one cut bad schools another cut
housing regulations that lead to boom
and bust cycles another cut powerful
unions that push for restrictive labor
laws another cut and on and on it goes
it's not always government policies that
force companies out but a long legal
battle with the city of Los Angeles
might end up being the Newcomb's final
cut Los Angeles has a business tax and
in 1993 they wanted to stick us in the
highest category and we fought that I
spent a small fortune on legal fees to
win that battle the city said the new
comes this letter verifying that creator
syndicate would not be forced into a
higher tax rate but then in 2008 city
officials sent this letter saying they
weren't bound by the original decision
and they were reversing their own ruling
and you can't have these bureaucrats
just arbitrarily saying oh we're not
bound by our own rulings not only did
the city put creator syndicate into a
higher tax rate but officials applied
the new decision retro actively
demanding $400,000 in back taxes this is
legalized theft and this is all the
paperwork that's accumulated over the
17-year legal fight with the city it's
cost the new comes about a million
dollars and it's counting the expensive
legal fight has forced the company to
layoff two employees and if the new
comes do have to pay the $400,000 in
back taxes they'll have to layoff
another ten the people of this town are
ready to get back to work
la mayor Antonio Villaraigosa likes to
talk about job creation and he's always
doing something he hopes will stimulate
the economy efforts to grow green too
bad he didn't want to talk to us because
it's this kind of job strangling red
tape that few people hear about until
they experience it themselves something
needs to be done or businesses will
continue to take their business
elsewhere for many that means leaving
gorgeous California for homely Texas the
top destination for Americans who move
to a different state you know we don't
have the mosquitoes that they have or
the swamps or the humidity the natural
climate might be rough but the business
climate is inviting Texas low taxes or
in certain cases like income no taxes
much fewer regulations traffic flows
better Texas throughout the recession
has actually shown growth or at least
minimal job loss both states added jobs
over the past decade then the recession
hit and Texas leveled off while
California hemorrhaged jobs they are
working every single day to spur job
creation but high unemployment persists
even though politicians have been doing
so much bipartisan economic rescue plan
jobs and don't forget about those
bailouts and the massive stimulus much
of which went to California I'm so happy
that we are getting this kind of
benefits from the federal government and
from President Obama instead of doing so
much
what if politicians devoted just one day
per year to undoing their worst blunders
it'd be a nice break from the norm and
it might even save and create some jobs
for Reason TV i'm ted bellacor